with almost 500 sessions at next 2018
it's understandable that you couldn't
get to them all so if you didn't see
best practices from Google Sree how you
can use them with gke and sto then stay
tuned because here's the rewind when
you're critical cloud applications are
up and running
you cannot afford downtime and so you
probably have many systems in place to
prevent and monitor your apps to find
out when they aren't happy thankfully
things can get a little easier for you
using a service mesh and standard
reliability practices okay so what's a
service mesh a service mesh is a way to
automate key functions of your network
for interrelated applications and to
accomplish that it's critical that this
tooling be transparent and language
agnostic giving you increased
flexibility instead of more integration
headaches think of a service mesh as an
open platform to manage how services
interact and give you insight into how
they depend on each other it does all of
this by adding a sidecar proxy either a
container or a little buddy for your VM
that will handle inbound and outbound
traffic apply policies and collect
metrics but don't worry you don't need
to build all this on your own
SDO is an open source service mesh that
you can use for great monitoring right
from the start providing key metrics for
observing the health of your services
like traffic errors and latency each key
metric is useful to help you track if
services outages are happening or where
disruption might be occurring in your
service mesh with is do you get
automated collection and dashboarding of
traffic errors and latency right out of
the box you can export these logs into
your bakery stack driver or any
third-party tool that you like and do
precise analysis alerting and reporting
that way you and your SAS can understand
exactly what's happening in your system
when there's an issue using sto you can
also roll out new versions of a service
carefully deploying a canary test for
analysis and measurement before you roll
out to all traffic this improves on
basic kubernetes functionality which
would split traffic across all pods
evenly but with ISTE O's tools you can
say test this new pod
with 1% of traffic without having to
deploy exactly 100 pots to hear more
about reliability best practices
Dickerson's hierarchy of reliability
needs as well as SLO SLA s and s lis
check out the full talk at the cloud
YouTube channel and don't forget to
subscribe for more great next rewind
content thanks for watching
you
[Music]